der vom mega sind die
wissen sie das nicht ein danke
[Musik]
hier drin herrschen panik angst und
blanke not denn bald kommen die täler
und nehmen den rechtschaffenden
abgeordneten die arbeitsplätze weg ein
erschütternder bericht von mir
der stift
in der stadt geht weil jeder fünfte
abgeordnete so heißt es wird seinen job
verlieren nächstes jahr ja dann warten
wir doch einfach mal die wahlen ab dann
werden wir sehen wer den job verliert
und wenn ich von welcher partei sind sie
bündnis 90 die grünen sieht man das
nicht so vorstellen dass morales
begleitet noch fröhlich aber wie wird es
bald aussehen aber darüber hinaus auch
sehr emotional was es bedeutet dann auch
einmal nicht mehr teil des politischen
betriebs zusammen und ist einfach
ausgespuckt worden aus dem nails tag
hinaus bestand also hat man hat man
freundin aufgefangen haben die einfach
meinen arm genommen haben haben gesagt
mensch komm mal her ist ein armer kerl
ist nein so schalter schon einmal das
hatte ich nicht ich bin sicher nichts
sehen und die verbitterung ich bin
relativ genau wo man am besten mit
ehemaligen angeleiteten dass es so dass
an der gleich mit denen sich darum zu
machen einfach vergessen muss dass man
auf einmal ausgesprochen haben
hallo ich grüße sie sie sind
abgeordneter
sie sind der abgeordnete liegen bei
ihnen die nerven blank neben mir liegen
die nerven nicht bleiben die ausstellung
für die nächste wahl laufen ja gerade
erst dort schnell schnell unterwegs und
zeit ist geld einfach mega sind die
wissen sie das nicht ein die beiden
ihr habt euch eure gute laune bewahrt
obwohl die zeit natürlich verdammt
bitter sind das stimmt die zeiten sind
betont jeder fünfte abgeordnete wird
seinen job verlieren wenn die fdp hier
einwandert angst um den arbeitsplatz
ich bin sowieso nur praktikant ihr
verein monat also ich von meinen
einige wanderte alt wie orden werden
unsere heimische politiker population
verdrängen schlimm die müssen sich dann
wohl andere jobs suchen die ihren
fähigkeiten entsprechen
[Musik]
diese abgeordnete die namentlich nicht
genannt werden möchte wenn wir sie
claudia r versucht die angst vor der
arbeitslosigkeit mit schreienden farben
zu betäuben ich kann mir nicht helfen
aber oft reicht das ja auch einfach nur
zuzuhören sie müssen mit mir reden ich
möchte heute show und tag und sie ich
bin von den grünen sie müssen gleich
eine rede halten ja zu dem thema zum
verkehrshaushalt wird es eine ihrer
letzten sein ich hoffe nicht auf jeden
fall werde ich an lob und auch nicht
angreifen farewell alles gute
wird also wirklich von meiner seite aus
es wird schon
von meiner seite aus toll toll toll
praktisch jeder fünfte abgeordnete wird
im nächsten deutschen bundestag nicht
mehr dabei sein er hat noch glück er hat
auch noch glück lucky guy
noch einmal davon gekommen doch er
leider nicht
vor dem hintergrund der aktuellen
ereignisse geht ihnen auch der stift
dass sie bald ihren job los sind
jeder fünfte abgeordnete so heißt es
wird im nächsten bundestag nicht mehr
dabei sein dann bin ich eben nicht nur
fünfte
viele zuschauer wenn demnächst ein
arbeitsloser abgeordneter vor ihrer tür
steht schicken sie ihn nicht weg geben
sie ihm einen teller suppe eine warme
decke oder einen gut bezahlten job in
ihrem lobbyverband herzlichen dank
[Applaus]
hallo leute ich bin der heute-show
[Musik]
hersteller wenn ihr mehr heißen scheiß
und 70 - wollt dann abonniert jetzt den
kanal
was zur hölle ist minimal hersteller
[Musik]